這一週算是一個強力反彈的格局
但是到了今天市場上有一點點
觀望的味道出來
當然等一下凱克也要探討
我們有信心有底氣在下週做佈局的
就是AI發展這件事情
完全完全不用去質疑他
但籌碼的動向我們來觀察
例如說投信這一波
有一些股票看都可以亂七八糟
所以今天有獨家的錯殺股
要幫我們找出來
外資的話 像被動元件
或是有其他的類股可以看見誰
是啊 其實這一波其實談得很快
但是其實有些人可能沒有撿到
再來是投信
其實在這個反彈過程裡面
其實他們也是兵荒馬亂
因為之前被迫停損
然後馬上大盤又漲到這邊
又有點覺得大盤好像漲派動了
現在我們就氣小重大
那我們看國際市場
最近這個Antropi就要掛牌了
這個台灣翻譯成安創培
安創培 聽起來很要命
聽起來很要命
但他就是安創培
這家公司基本上
他的高階主管都是從OpenAI出來的
是
所以接下來公司是很會做算力
很會做算力
所以你看Google說他要投資安創培400億美元
然後做一個付買回
你看2000億美元的回購
因為他答應說他要買有Gigawad的TPU
然後在這個Amazon也要投資他331億
所以告訴你其實這個暫局
其實越開越大
所以之前前面有一段時間
大家在講這個NVIDIA的這個債容支計畫
這邊大家把AI算力
當作是一個可融資的商品
但其實這是有點風險
就是因為GPU這個東西
基本上它不是基建
不是基礎建設
基礎建設可能十年二十年
它可以慢慢回收賺它的利率
可是GPU其實它跌價
尤其現在是美國不能賣
讓中國買到高級的GPU
所以它到時候萬一這個
下去是不是這個價格的部分
是不是造成很大的變化
所以你可以看到這個
好
揮達發佈這個消息之後
股價是幾乎要創歷史新高
可是呢
正當後的
高森發佈完之後
沒有上去
你說融資要負責連帶的這個銀行
所以其實對他而言
不見得是一個好消息
是
但是因為對美國市場來講
現在因為房地產狀況不是很好
所以他們要另批新戰場
所以他們就選擇這一個
AI融資
而且我覺得對他們有個好處
就是他們可以看到很多公司
未來的計劃
對
因為你要來跟我借錢
你一定要把你的Planetation告訴我
對 那很多公司其實台灣也是這樣子
很多券商其實都很早就看到
公司的籌資計畫
所以他們都知道未來的幾年
公司會長成什麼樣子
所以很多券商都在這裡面大賺特賺
所以我們投資人也要利用
公司在錯籌資的時候
看懂他們的公開說明書
這是一個美港
好 接下來我們來看的就是
為什麼說很多人怎麼樣
在這一波裡面
投信急急忙忙的下車
可是我們發覺有些公司
其實沒有這麼的差
例如說他們在殺聯電
殺南茂 殺京居 殺曾鼎
我覺得他們好像有點殺錯了
殺錯了
他們還殺0050
對 就是他們其實就是很急著下車
因為這個盤讓他們有點嚇到了
這是過去一週啦 過去一週
好 過去一週
等於是台股在反彈
可是投信這些股票下車
對 就是我就說
因為他們急著下車
所以有時候你很匆忙的要出國
什麼你會積極忙忙帶一些東西
把你帶出的東西
或是拿東西沒帶
好東西沒帶
那我在講說
這裡面其實特別是連電
連電特別是連電
為什麼 因為其實你看這幾天
其實像利基電愛普都在漲
為什麼
因為他們都在漲細電容
細電容
但其實連電也是細電容的成員之一
華邦電不是也是
華邦電不是
不是
所以我覺得市長有點搞太清楚
是
就是目前以國內來講
會參與細電農的經元代工的
只有聯電跟利基電
所以市長常常講說
利基電是唯一家
這也是不對的
但是這兩家的IP
都是從IP出來
所以IP應該是實質受惠
那你看他今天就
這今天的漲幅
我不是講
反正今天是漲的
好今天漲的
其實你看這些被挫殺的股票
其實今天好像
除了像聯電是跌了以外
其實都沒有什麼跌
有沒有
可是今天盤不太好
對不對 那旅程上應該是
投信把它殺下去
應該是要跟著往下殺
可是在今天這兩天
你發覺好像不是這樣子
好像你慢慢要上來了
那這邊還有一個
跟著南亞同伯這個調漲報價的
金居今天也跟著往上漲
我跟著往上漲
那記憶體不用講嘛
我上次講過
其實記憶體的顆粒還在漲價
顆粒還在漲價
他做到的封裝怎麼可能會差
一定也不會差嘛
所以你看他的七月業績
其實就很好
其實說創個歷史新高
看起來趨勢還在往上走
所以我覺得南貓有點被挫折
而且他上半年就已經賺了快
兩塊多了吧
所以今年應該
大概minima就是接近五塊錢的水準
五塊錢的水準
現在九十一塊九其實也不貴啊
也不貴
再來就是真頂ky
我覺得其實他真的很倒楣
對 就是一直被這HDI版干擾到
對
但是我一直跟你講說
不要看HDI版
大家看ABF
對
因為前一陣子
這個長廣
他就開個法說
他就說整個一個ABF的產業狀況
是 從二零二五年一直隨到二零二六年
我是說隨了 倒楣
倒楣二六六年
現在開始要脾氣太大了
他只要二零二八年
都看得非常的正面
而且他的產能供不應求
載板本來就在今年是夯的
對 所以南電隊已經要創新高人
你說真頂怎麼可能會在這個地方
被投信怎樣
把它埋沒了
所以會覺得投信有時候在殺股票
有時候殺得有點莫名其妙
我們一黨一黨來看
連電 你第一個黨喊冤的
對 你看投信其實怎麼樣
狂賣 可是人家在外資怎麼樣
狂買啊 藍叫喊冤
人家外資是狂買
可是我們投信平民狂賣
今天可能有些
今天沒有關係 在小調節沒關係
好 換形態
形態當然這裡是有一個大量的壓力
在這裡沒有錯
可是這一段其實它也沒有什麼量啊
這也沒什麼量
所以我覺得它是反彈的格局
那這是周K
對 我們開日K
你看一樣是這樣的形態
這樣的型態
我說他已經 這個景線位子已經站穩了
他這樣就是慢慢往上爬
所以我覺得他
應該也是會慢慢回去
慢慢回去
他可能也有被ETF調節
好 那我們來看一下
大家都講的立基電
立基電 這是立基電的
近期強談 你看他已經快要來到這裡了
快要來到這裡
而且他已經站上了日的大量低
日的大量低
外資很愛他 對
那我說假設立基電的細電容
是一個可以買的故事
那聯店當然也是一個可以買的故事
因為他就是有
他就是有
那當然因為他頭心不多
所以他們有被頭心砍殺
但聯店就是頭心很多
所以是被扎實
我們是拿來做對比的
對
所以我就說
如果你在看立基店
其實你也不要忘記
還有一檔聯店可以買
而且相對未接還比較便宜
還便宜
接著我們來看的就是
艾普
那這就是大家公認的
就是他其實就是有系電容
這是周K
周的大量低在這裡
好
周的大量高在這裡
所以他已經過周大量高了
他已經過大量高了
對
那這是日的形態
日的形態
基本上日的大量高就在這裡
所以也是站上
所以我覺得
細電容這個題材
確實是一個很明確的題材
因為未來是一名筆
會大量的產出
他們就需要細電容
所以我覺得找這個題材
做到明年我覺得都OK
因為這時間其實大家就找不到
未來的趨勢
因為大部分談到這邊
很多人覺得老故事
沒有什麼新東西
可是我剛剛講
像ABF
然後都跟你講說
好到2028年
之前凱克在講大家都不太相信
可是陸續什麼南殿 景碩都出來講
看起來好像是真的
看起來是真的
所以我說
曾瑩其實被殺了有無辜
等於是雖然老故事
但是現在看起來是惡度發育了
惡度成長
對 惡度成長了
所以我們剛剛講說
我講說西電農這個族群
其實是可以把它包起來一起看
結果我們剛才講的就是
南茂 機體風車
那南茂頭巾還在殺
這砍得好兇啊
頭巾還在殺
這一比八千多張
但我覺得啦
當然就是說
因為這裡有個大量低
被殺下來了
那他也談了一段到這裡了
到這裡了
但我覺得他應該也是
屬於被措殺的
因為我說
第一個是業績真的是好的
因為他七月以後
是創一個新高
然後EPS也是在往上的增加
那我們要看到
整個一個南亞科的一個狀況
其實是好的
所以告訴你說
目前看起來肌體風樁
不會有什麼太大的疑慮
那只要南亞科往上
它就會跟著往上
那我們就開始金居
金居其實你看
頭興開始怎麼樣
開始回來
這兩天終於回補
之前賣了一萬多張
那我覺得這可能也跟今天
這個南亞科
同伯報價上場有關係
大量在這裡
是
所以我覺得
他們也殺了差不多了
今天同伯類都好厲害
殺得差不多
那但是這地方看起來
有一點點還是有點虛
還是有點虛
不過我覺得也是會跟著往上走
因為其實他的
不管是目前的四五
基本上這兩個規格
都已經在交貨中
而且他還在擴三期長
在雲林要擴他一個三期的
產能出來
而且我那天有特別去看了一下
這個日本的這個三井
三井金樹
他說他到2028年要大幅的增加 AI 的同伯
表示什麼
表示同伯虛胸增加很強
真的很強
所以我覺得這有可能被挫殺
是
接著就是增典
我們剛剛曾經就幫他講過
我覺得ABF真的是好啦
所以你不要一直看他的 HDI
所以你就把它
沒有看了
而且他給你很好的位階去買
因為你像什麼南電啊 景色
結果都已經快要到這個位置了
先先也站上1000以上了
對 都在這個位置
所以我覺得他相對是一個好的買點
而且你看外資投信也開始同步
所以我們在這個裡面
開始從貝殼裡面找珍珠
就是說不要覺得這時間是沒有辦法買的
還是可以有好的股票可以讓你
只是你就是多花一點時間去找
好那我們接下來講就是說
不管是MNCI或挪威主權基金
其實都有買被動員
目前談了一些了
對但是其實我必須講
就是挪威主研基金
其實他比較像是退休基金
對
所以他買了股票
理論上是趨勢
他是買趨勢的股票
他不是買高股息的概念
對 他是趨勢的概念
可是他是一個退休基金
所以他是要買比較長線
至少是長線不準
所以你看他的錢時大
一定都是耳熟能詳的標的
台積電啦
對 都是大的
鴻海啊
但是能夠被他選進去
基本上一定也有他的理由
但是他比較特殊
因為他沒有基金
經理人直接在handle這個股票
那他認為就一定
所以他其實是有點委台灣的
對 難怪他有買
我記得好像日電帽
還是什麼 最後你都問一下
他就是委託給台灣的基金公司
但是這是一部分
一部分
所以我覺得你可以多觀察他的股票
就是說他除了十大以外
會去買的股票
通常都是有一定的nitch
會有一定的故事
所以大家會覺得說
為什麼他們國劇就不用講
為什麼跑去買核酸糖
對 那其實我們核酸糖就講過
因為它是這個AI裡面的
MLCC的存量是比較高的
存度最高 存量比較高的
那我們也講說
你可以透過核酸糖的股價
去模擬操作國劇的股價
我們之前有好幾個分析師來
都一直在講說國劇華信科嘛
我們就講說
你先看他再來操作這兩檔
會比較風險會比較低
我今天被動是回的比較明顯
今天排名上比較沒有被動的消息
對
那你用就純度來講
他是比較高
是
那你說要
他要取代他
我覺得不太容易
不太容易
因為產品的特性
產品的特性
我們來看一下型態
你看這是國具
你看投信也還在買
所以他這邊的下殺
某種程度我覺得
就是他第二季的EP20
其實並不特別的亮麗
不特別亮麗
所以看起來他是有一點點壓力在這裡
但是也還沒到
你看你把這一根跟這一根抓起來
有沒有
這一根這一根抓起來
你就發覺其實他還有一段距離
還沒有滿足
反而看到外資對他
賣的時候也是蠻兇狠的
是投信在挺他
因為我們看到其實大部分的ETF投信
都有他
那何生長之前講過
因為他這一段是因為被處置的關係
所以這一段是殺的莫名其妙
所以很多人死在這裡
最後被砍出來
所以這一段
他算彈得強的
這一段相對來講就是真空
真空 用真空來形容
所以他回到這裡
基本上這裡整理完
應該還會再往上走
至於他能不能過這裡
我覺得就再看看
不過我個人覺得
目前投信在買
而且整個第三季
其實他們的報價
確實還有往上走的空間
因為包括日本也在講說
這報價還要再調漲
所以我覺得你可以先看核酸糖
再來操作的國具
應該會是比較好的操作
也等於剛剛講到核酸糖
一直把它列為是被動元件的領頭
因為它的AI純度
我覺得這個大家還可以去思量
這件事情
這邊非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝趙華